what's more fun than pair programming
asynchronous remote massive-scale pair
programming in 2011 I presented an i/o
session pro tips for building
context-aware apps those tips went into
a sample app the targets Android
Honeycomb
and supports cupcake it's android 1.6 if
you're keeping track that covered 98% of
active devices in 2011 today it's less
than 3.2 percent
clearly it's time to do an update I
asked if you'd like to watch me go
through the process of updating the app
and you said yes so despite some
skepticism you know they're just
trolling you right nobody wants to watch
you write code on YouTube I don't know
there's like the Facebook movie Silicon
Valley CSI cyber scorpion these are all
really really popular and this is a lot
like them this is nothing like them well
wait you haven't been telling people
that this is like them right because
this is nothing like that this would be
boring strong skepticism I'm giving it a
shot
the result is pivotal it's a lot like
cereal it's not like that either
each episode is part of a larger story
having an app targeting an API that's
fallen off the sliding scale of
relevancy is a great opportunity to
replace tricks hacks and deprecated API
s with a robust modern architecture that
means integrating the Android support
library the fuse location provided the
jobscheduler material design enhanced
notifications Android wear and all the
features of Ice Cream Sandwich jelly
bean KitKat lollipop and marshmallow and
everything else I don't yet realize it
needs to be updated you won't see much
of me but imagine me here dressed neatly
at a tidy desk with a warm cup of tea
definitely do not picture me with my
feet up on a messy desk and absolutely
not me at home in my pajamas picture me
here in my happy place
rado we're going to need you to clear
out of here we've got another shoot
can't you do this at your desk I'm Rena
Maya join me on the Android developers
YouTube channel as I bring in all that
back to the future here in my office
welcome to pivotal